we do this question just says here's a
polynomial you divide by this you'll get
that remainder
you divide by this you get a different
remainder okay so how does it work well
it's a pretty straight use of the
remainder theorem
right let's take this first line and the
zero
zero that corresponds to x minus 3 is 3.
so you just say p of 3 is going to be
120.
okay so you come up here and you say
well what does that mean you substitute
it all in
you're going to get on the left hand
side 2
times 27 plus 7
times 9 plus 3a
plus b that's 120 yes
so i've got 54 plus
63 plus these two guys
so you subtract both those
both of those are what uh 117 so i'm
going to end up with
three over here yes and that's going to
be
one of my simultaneous equations i know
i'm going to need two because i've got
two unknowns
right all right there's my first
equation make your second one
by taking this equation so in the same
way
p of minus one is minus eight you
rehearse
the same thing two times minus one
plus seven times one minus
a plus b that's going to give me minus
eight
so far so good minus two plus seven
minus a plus b equals minus eight
that's five so you take it over you get
minus thirteen and there's your second
equation
okay now assuming my numbers are okay
and i'm in a hurry so i'm not going to
bother checking
from here that's fine no problems you
guys know how to solve simultaneous
equations okay and you probably already
have your answer for this okay
but these are the important two things
that you want to get in your work in
okay because it shows you understand
what romantic theory is are you kind of
this question
let me just try to word it for you
because it's a bit succinct
they say there is a polynomial and they
even tell you what it is okay so it's
not
this kind of scenario they do they do
tell you that it's got degree greater
than three so it could be four five six
seven eight
right and then they give you similar
information to what they had before
if you divide by this you'll get this
remainder divide by this you'll get this
remainder
okay now the question is
what happens when you divide by both of
them at the same time
what happens when you divide by x minus
4
x plus 3 okay the product of those two
divisors right what remainder will you
get in such a case
all right now the first thing you want
to notice is that
when you divide by something with um a
degree
one okay what you end up with as a
remainder
has degree zero right you should
probably put a d there
okay which makes sense because when you
divide numbers right i think the example
i gave you like 300 divided by seven
okay the remainder you're going to get
is always going to be less than
your divisor wouldn't it make sense to
get one equal to or more than
what your divisor is okay now since
polynomials it's not about numbers
it's about what power is on x that's how
we divide through polynomials okay
the same principle carries here now if
i'm dividing by
a divisor with degree 2 i should expect
my remainder to have
degree one okay so
therefore i'm going to set up my
remainder theorem like this
i'm going to say p of x right when i
divide through by both of these things
if i actually knew what p was okay i'd
get those and then i'd get a quotient
at the end which would itself be another
polynomial call it q for quotient
okay but then assuming it doesn't divide
through it actually has a remainder
it will have a remainder of degree one
now if it's degree one it's
some x and some constant so i'm gonna
call that
sorry a x plus b this
that's the remainder that i'm after okay
that's kind of a crucial step it's hard
to see
because it's like well i just sort of
made it up okay but this is actually
what i'm solving for
now once you've got that set up this
question just by starting so differently
proceeds just like this one right
because i'll say i'll say look
on the basis of this the remainder
theorem tells me that p of four
will be four okay so you sub it in now i
don't i don't know what p
is but i don't need to okay because
because of the remainder theorem when i
put four
in this part will just vanish okay and
i'll be left with this okay
but it's got an x in it so that's going
to be 4x
plus b see that is that okay
all right again first of my two
equations
uh sorry yeah that's right i subbed it
in for x okay
you repeat it for this so that means p
of minus
three will be minus ten
okay so therefore again it's going to be
minus three
a gotta write this time plus b equals
minus 10.
okay now because this just looks a
little different uh
up here i'm just going to solve it for
you and finish it what are we going to
do how should i combine them
looks like i'll subtract yeah
1 minus 2 that's going to give you 7 a
equals 14. so that gives you a
and if you bring that back up here
that's going to be 8 plus b
is 4 so b is minus 4.
okay now that's not the answer right
usually they say just tell me what a and
b
are the question was what is the
remainder so you've got to bring that in
and say the remainder will be 2 x minus
4. looks different it's the same
question just in different clothes